well the thing that you're likely to be
world-class at is whatever you obsessed
over from say age 12 to 18 it's just not
that helpful on a day to day basis and
so like that I lost most of my interest
for it what makes a successful person
they go out and solve big problems rise
and shine it's an espresso time what's
up believe nation it's Evan my one word
is believe and this channel is designed
to be a part of your daily success
routine so let's start your day I've
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message do what your 12 year
old self wanted over you Bill Gates also
if you want to know what Bill Gates and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series who are every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video or free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below I believe in the
internet I believe it'll get
increasingly popular and we're doing
some neat new things to take advantage
of that and my question to you is if you
suddenly find yourself to be say a
sophomore in college at Harvard what do
you think you would study and how do you
think you'd spend your time engaging
activities well the thing that you're
likely to be world-class at is whatever
you obsessed over from say age 12 to 18
you know in my case it was writing
software where I would think I was good
and then I would meet somebody who would
tell me I wasn't and I would look at
their code and I went through four sort
of comeuppance ha's of oh that's what a
really good programmer looks like and
part of the reason I worshipped digital
equipment was eventually it was a couple
of their very best programmers who came
and shared with me how they thought
about how they did thing and I had
studied their code and and I and there
there were several people who were so
key am I doing that so today I would go
into you know software which today that
going into artificial intelligence you
know computers still can't read they
they cannot take a book of information
and say pass an AP test on that book and
that's a solvable problem but it's a
knowledge representation problem and you
know I've always want me to solve that
problem I'm jealous that maybe one of
you gets to work on that you know
unlikely to go back and be hands-on in
that in that way but it's the juiciest
problem ever I've thought about it for a
long time so I would go into AI doing
what you're 12 to 18 year old self
obsessed over is dangerous advice it
gives you little context it helps you
understand yourself a little bit better
it's another point of reference but
using it as a blanket statement you
going in thinking the thing that I
should be doing in life is the thing
that I was obsessed over when I was 12
to 18 is dangerous advice when I was 12
years old I obsessed over the Toronto
Blue Jays
I loved the Blue Jays I loved baseball I
went every year to spring training in
Florida to get autographs
I collected baseball cards while other
kids wanted to go to Florida over spring
break to go to Disney World
I wanted to go to Dunedin Stadium and
hang out with the Blue Jays and follow
them when they gotta their parking lot
and I knew every single player from
Roberto Alomar Joe Carter superstars
down to vince horsemen who nobody else
knew and I went in asking for his
autograph on a baseball I love the Blue
Jays absolutely obsessed about the Blue
Jays and now I barely watch any games
haven't been to a game all year and I
love watching eSports
and a much more fan of TSM and legal
edges in high school I was obsessed with
stocks in my yearbook it said I wanted
to be a banker where you gonna be in ten
years VP at a bank that's what I thought
I wanted I was obsessed with stocks I
only had two three thousand dollars
invested but I watched that money every
single day I opened up the newspaper at
the time every single day I understood
p/e ratios I was researching warren
buffett strategies I was looking to
value investing momentum investing
everything I loved it I was so deep into
the stock trading world that I was
convinced that this was a thing I was
going to be doing I loved it
now I've got four holdings Facebook
Amazon a Canadian bank the Intel Co I
check in really once a month I make a
trade maybe once a quarter and I invest
everything that gets paid out back into
the stocks it's still important Wealth
Management is important it's not my
obsession anymore in university I loved
economics especially macroeconomics I
thought it was amazing I thought it
explained everything and explained
economies that we'd be able to build
businesses from it that'd explain human
behavior I just I was so deep into the
world of macroeconomics I loved it I
studied it all my friends are going out
I was diving into economics research on
my summer jobs I would print off
encyclopedias of economics to read about
economic history like weirdly obsessed
about economics and then I found out
that you know what like being an
entrepreneur it's just not that relevant
makuu economics barely touch what
entrepreneurs do it's just not that
helpful on a day-to-day basis and so
like that I lost most of my interest for
it so I share this with you because
everything I did from age 12 to 18 I'm
not doing much of anymore it's not my
obsession anymore at all I'm a big
believer that your purpose comes from
your pain I think if you're struggling
to figure out what you should do with
your life what business you want to run
dig deep into what pain that you have
been through and how you have solved it
or still solving it right now and that
is going to be at the core of what you
end up doing you want to make the pain
that you had less for other people who
are currently going through that pain I
think that is something that will live
with you forever I think humans are
built to serve and I think is based off
of problems that you have been through
yourself but I don't think it has to
have been something that happened to you
while you were 12 to 18 years old I
think it's an arbitrary number it's
useful again as a point of context but
don't accept it as a blanket rule for
what you should be doing with your
purpose in life another quick example
just to really bring this home because
that finding your purpose what you
should do in life is one of the most
important questions that I keep getting
asked consistently and so I want you to
have the right advice I look at Candice
Lightner she started a group called
Mothers Against Drunk Driving mad it's
it's a leading organization that
how to prevent people from driving drunk
why did she start that organization it
became her life's work right her life's
passion why did she start it because her
13 year old daughter was killed by drunk
driver it wasn't because of what
happened when she was 12 years old or 13
or 14 or 16 or 18 who is because when
her daughter was 13 years old she was
killed by a drunk driver and her mom
wanted to do something to feel empowered
to make sure that no other parent had to
go through this again
her purpose comes from her pain
regardless of when that happens in life
so what do you do when you get this
advice from one person saying something
and another person saying something else
another person saying something else
honestly the best thing is try on the
hat try on their hat and see if the
advice fits my goal is not to be the
next Steve Jobs but I can learn one
thing from Steve Jobs to help make me
better and a lot of his other advice
isn't relevant to me might even be
opposite of what I believe in I don't
want to be a father like Steve Jobs was
but I want to be a visionary like he is
you know I want to be a parent like my
parents are but I don't want to be
entrepreneurs like they were so you try
on different hats
so Bill's telling you one thing I'm
telling you another thing there's lots
of rules for success that I cover on
this channel sometimes they can seem
overwhelming don't let it be just try on
the hat listen to what Bill Gates said
here does it make sense for you is there
something from when you were 12 to 18
that you're really passionate about that
maybe you want to tap into go try it out
listen to what I'm saying your purpose
comes from your pain is there a pain in
your past that is so prevalent that you
want to make it easier for other people
who are going through that same thing
right now try it on see if it works for
you that's it that's the best advice Ron
Marlon success your goal is not to be
the next Bill Gates Steve Jobs Evan
Carmichael whoever it's to be the best
you and that's gonna come from taking
different bits from different people
trying on the Hat and see what works for
you now I've got a really special bonus
clip that I think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day I want to know how
have you found your purpose if you found
the thing that you love doing how did
you find it what were the steps what was
a process I think other people could
really benefit from learning from your
experience - leave it down in the
comments
though
the Laveen the billionaire formula is
simple what makes a successful person
they go out and solve big problems so
you know how to be make a billion
dollars
he solved with ten billion dollar
problem having already made his billions
he now unashamedly wants to use his
business brain to change our world let's
focus on education health care energy
shortage of water shortage of food and
I'm going to tell you how innovation and
entrepreneurship can solve each of these
problems let's look at education imagine
if you are able to use it $25 tablet and
build some type of a game that's more
effective than a private tutor and it's
more addictive than the most addictive
video game think about it one day a
child is going to come to the mother you
say mom can I just play one more hour of
math because I enjoy it so much
naveen has a knack of putting people
under his spell making his mission to
solve some of mankind's biggest problems
seem plausible in space and on earth
intelligence system that can be used by
a village girl she'll be able to go door
to door and able to diagnose the
diseases where there are no health care
there's no hospitals there are no
doctors these are bigger ideas that
could turn a big profit but some of them
seem a bit far-fetched what if we take a
3d printer on the moon and somebody can
go out and send the DNA of a bacteria or
a virus and we printed right there and
leave it in the moon and watch it grow
these are tears they're a bit out there
on anything don't people think you're
just a bit mad what the point is that
the reason they think is mad because
it's already they don't know it's
already happening the things that used
to be science fiction are now becoming
science reality I was born here but um
so my mom had me auditioned for this
company and because they're holding
auditions
oh she was talented early mom saw it
early I mean you know she so it wasn't
that she saw it early so this is what it
is she wanted me to be like a doctor a
lawyer my grades were bad obviously I
wasn't gonna go to you know like I
wasn't gonna get into a university
because I was always breakdancing and I
was always that goddamn hip-hop yeah
so you know I started off as a b-boy and
battling and all that and then um she's
just like okay let's see where you stand
go audition for this thing they're doing
this thing and then I went and did it
and they you know they're like y'all
being this boyband so I wasn't like a
boyband for like at first they
definitely you know didn't like the fact
because I could have been doing like
more pop so it just took like an easier
route but then you know this is what
this is me so it's just kind of like I
just had to do me and then just
hopefully they would see and now they're
not complaining you know it's like they
live in everything's coming in live in
the house about them and they you know
and obviously it's not I'm not out here
running amuck you know I'm very I'm a
very positive person I do a lot for my
people I do a lot for you know just
everybody that's around me so if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon now
if you want more advice from
billionaires around the world check out
the video right next to me I think
you're gonna enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
so every year forms make a list of the
richest people in the world many of them
are entrepreneurs and I thought it'd be
a fun idea to take some of the very best
advice to help us get stronger